I think a lot of people say it's harder
because you don't have the edge you
don't work as hard that's not true with
me if you talk to anyone who works with
me they'll say I'm working as hard now
as I was during my first company when I
was blowing through my 401k to finance
it
[Music]
all right Paul what's going on man will
you uh darmesh CTO co-founder HubSpot
told us we have to we have to we don't
we don't have to but we should talk to
you
what uh why did he say that I don't know
it's going to be connected
um damesh and I
have a lot of uh fun talking together
about technology philosophy and teams
um one fun thing that demesh and I did
going back many years ago now when I was
CTO profender of kayak
damesh and I kind of switched jobs for a
day so I actually had him made up I got
him an email address dumbass kayak.com
and made up business cards and he
basically sat at my desk at card for day
and then I sat at HubSpot for a day and
that was sort of the beginning of our
friendship realizing that we each had
someone over that but some things we can
learn from each other and he's been a
great mentor to me and friend
and your big hit has been well so far
you have a new company Lola which I
don't know if you know this or not you
guys advertised with my old company the
hustle a bit so yeah uh we worked with
you a bit but um
your big hit so far has been kayak right
what did you sell that for like two or
three billion two billion I've actually
sold six companies in a row including
Lola I've sold even another one after
Lola Moonbeam which is a podcast app and
now I'm on to my seventh company
which one of the which so which of the
six has been the most financially
successful for you tag was the biggest
Financial outcome
um which I'm deeply appreciative of and
I learned a lot at I met some
amazing people but there's other things
which are also really significant that
aren't just monetary so my first sale I
don't have to I just told you I sold six
in a row there's another one that I
don't really count because it only was a
company I created in high school but
it's very meaningful to me making money
in high school designing software and
what were the six so I had to come pick
up Boston light we were an e-commerce
company we let people set up storefronts
a little bit like Shopify but if this
goes back 20 years ago we sold that to
Intuit I began VP technology different
to it then I had a company called
intermute which is internet security
software I did that with my brother Ed
English we saw that to Trend Micro I did
a company gethuman.com which is served
customer service information over 200
million people kayak
Moonbeam the podcast player Lola which
is the business travel and expense and
did I forget one I think that's the list
and so what's the like
um thought process so would did you
start them all in kind of the same way
where you were maybe scratching your own
itch or you're like analyzing Trends so
like what's your process to come up with
these ideas it's mostly scratching my
own itch I mean I could go through a
company by company the only one that
wasn't my original idea was kayak my
co-founder Steve Hafner is one of the
founders of Orbitz and he had observed
it over it says 70 of the people that
just search on orbits but then when they
were done they opened a second browser
and went directly to united.com remember
to buy the ticket and so Orbitz did all
the searching for people but never made
money and so Steve base said why don't
create a company where all we do is
search and then if someone wants to go
to United they click the link and we'll
send them directly to United and they
could buy a fair and that was his
observation we met by chance and within
probably 45 minutes decided to sign up
as co-founders each put a million
dollars into the uh original round of
financing and then I very quickly owned
it from a product standpoint I went I'm
about to spend an hour on Expedia that
night
because Expedia was the market leader at
that point and just going back the next
morning saying this isn't going to be
hard because I looked at expedias below
where it was sort of seizure inducing
there was so much stuff going on the
screen you put a million dollars in was
that like a I'm going all my chips on
the table right now or was that a you
know was that half your net worth was
that a small bet for you how did you
feel at that time was did that add some
anxieties to the process I just sold a
company for 30 million so I could have
the the million wasn't that hard for me
at that point my prior company that I
sold for 30. I blew through my 401k to
finance it so my my first company was
tough financially
uh to get it going but for kayak I'd
made some money so I could afford to um
help Finance it why did you why do you
sell your companies why not you know try
to run them or have them exist under a
management team that you you control for
a long time like darmesh right darmesh
has been doing HubSpot for forever yeah
so kayak I did for 10 years that was my
longest stint and we ended up taking it
public 2012 which is incredibly fun and
then we sold it shortly thereafter the
price on at really booking.com which is
the parent company and I just frankly
was bored I felt like I was editing the
flight screen for 10 years and I wanted
to try something new and I'd had an
unbelievably strong team
at Tech leadership at kayak so at that
point I felt like I could sneak out
without hurting the company because I
had people that wanted to do UI they
could do product they could do
architecture so it gave me the freedom
to try something new you you're kind of
I mean you're you're kind of like an
internet OG a little bit I mean kayak's
one of the was like a pretty huge thing
it still is a huge thing but in terms of
like internet exits it was it was it was
early on in the game and you guys had a
nice huge exit who are some of the
people who are kind of like big shots
and Ballers now that you got to know a
little bit earlier on
um you mean across the industry overall
yeah because like darmesh has all these
crazy stories where he's like you know I
was an early investor in coinbase and I
and I met the team and I thought well he
didn't actually tell me this I'm just
making I mean he did invest in coinbase
but I'm sure there's like a story he's
like well I met this guy Brian and he
was like living out of a closet and
doing all this weird stuff and he was a
quirky guy and I mean he just has met or
I believe he was an early investor in
Dropbox as well and like he probably has
all these interesting stories about some
of these folks who are now like tycoons
or big deal now but he was fortunate
because he's a little bit older and was
more successful than they were when they
were just getting their things started
that he got insight into these
businesses do you have anything like
that yeah so I met Brian chesky at
Airbnb when they were financing a
billion dollar evaluation and I think
they're now with 100 billion or
something like that and I remember the
time like loving Brian thought he was
iconic
um and passion driven mission-driven
but um I didn't see it how big everybody
was gonna get I said this seems
awesome for people one of strangers
living in the house but how many people
is that going to be so I kind of missed
the bigger picture there
um what was he like when you met him
just kid like he was I mean I've seen
him talk and my wife works there I
totally agree I think he is an icon I
think he's one of the best CEOs out
there he's passion driven he's amazing
um but what did you see I saw him as
very serious and intense
um he was charismatic he listened well
so we had a good conversation where he
wanted me to give him feedback of the
company because kayak was a much bigger
company at that point and
um
yeah I just looked at this very serious
intense and charismatic yeah whenever
you're like you're doing technology for
like 15 20 years you just get this like
crazy story arc or like you know um you
get to see people you can you see all
these people that you're like all right
I think this person's kind of amazing
they might go on to do amazing things
maybe it's this idea maybe it's the next
idea are there any other stories like
that of uh that you've seen because
you've been kind of in the game for such
a long time
yeah so when we financed we was
created in 2004
uh We've really launched out of General
Catalyst in Cambridge Mass
and then we raised money from Mike
Moritz to Korea I remember one day my
co-founder and I were working out of the
support office
and Mike Moritz said oh I wanted to use
it a couple guys
this is Chad Hurley and let's get his
co-founder but they were the founders of
YouTube Steve I think yeah that's right
I remember meeting those guys at the
square office and Mike's like yeah these
guys are like putting videos online I'm
like yeah that's cool whatever
I didn't see that one either I have I
have some famous misses I mean I've been
very lucky as an investor
um I think my irr is 30.5 percent over
the last several years so I've been
pretty good I've invested in 60
companies but I've missed some I missed
Snapchat I met one of their Founders
when they were financing an 80 million
evaluation that would have been a big
outcome uh Dropbox Summit Drew early on
and that wasn't under the guise of me
investing in them it was really just
networking but had I I thought Dropbox
going to be plagued by security I'm
still kind of shocked I used Dropbox do
you know that they don't really encrypt
your files and then a Dropbox engineer
if they're malicious at get at toast
your files yeah I believe that it's
amazing that they're as big as they are
and why doesn't anyone
worry about anything yeah what have been
what have been the uh you said you've
invested in 60 companies and you got
this great IR what have been somebody
the hits so far
um one of the ones coming up right now
is pilot.com
and yeah that's an amazing company
I met those guys when they were I was a
judge at the MIT 100K competition and
had a company called case Place really
exotic technology they could patch a
Linux operating system as was running so
you don't have to reboot your servers
they sold that to Oracle I was part of
you know I was the judge at that and I
helped them win that competition and
then I invested the next company zulup
which they ended up selling to
um
the Dropbox
and then when they left Dropbox create
another company I basically asked if I
could invest before I knew what they
were working on so I wrote them a check
before I knew what they were doing and
that's a 40xr
I think I financed some I wrote a check
as part of the rounded 30 million
evaluation I think their last valuation
was like 1.2 billion or something but
that's one that the founding team had
the Mojo So when you met them you just
knew those guys going to create
something serious they they were intense
high energy they laughed a lot they
finished each other's sentences they
just really enjoyed working together
um I also not a good return for me at
22x was
Ken show which is a competitor to a
Bloomberg terminal
and I invested in them because their
seat show Pete Cresco used to work at
kayak and I knew him from kayak and I
just knew he was destined to do great
things and he that was a really nice
asset we we had this guy Trung work for
us so Trung was an analyst at Ken show
and Ken show is like this I you know
they're a startup still but like uh The
Stereotype to me from an outsider
they've kind of fit this like stereotype
of like an uptight Financial firm and we
found Trung working there and this guy
Trung who works for us he's like the
he's got he's a loudmouth like literally
like he speaks so loud and he's full of
energy and he was a writer for us and we
taught him how to you know we like
encouraged him to use Twitter and now
he's got like you know a million
followers on Twitter and we and we
recruited him from Ken show that's
amazing I like Ken show because of that
thank you
um and you so kayak was a big win
um and then you did things like let's
say Moonbeam which is like you know a
podcast discovery type app could have
been big but you know maybe I think
anything in podcasting is is sort of
like looks sort of Niche and most of the
podcast products even that win are sort
of like you know really good lifestyle
businesses so far there hasn't been that
many big winners in the podcasting space
in terms of tools
um are you do you I know one thing
that's hard I've talked to people who
kind of have an exit like 700 million or
800 million or a billion dollars it's
like that becomes the new table Stakes
for the next thing they do some go that
way and they say okay I Gotta Get huge
now and others are like no I'm literally
just gonna program things in my house
for fun now like now I I I don't want to
go try to catch lightning in a bottle
again which way uh do you think about it
or is there another Third Way
I've always said for each of my
companies it's team for Us customer
second profit third
I set up for kayak on day one we put
together our culture plan and I really
think it's a good way to execute because
if you if you focus on becoming a
phenomenal recruiter and really becoming
a student of recruiting but read all the
books listen to the podcasts learn from
others and talk about recruiting and
recruit an amazing team and then figure
out how to lead that team so that
there's no stress in the office people
work really hard they have fun they're
cranking stuff out but they're not
stressing each other out if you do those
things you can create I always say magic
teams create magical products
and then usually if you can create a
magical product you can find a profit of
business there so for me now after I
sold
um Lola my business travel and expense
company I sold that to Capital One a
year ago I then opened up a venture
studio called Boston Adventure Studio
it's bbs.net and we have nine apps under
development some of them are in itch to
scratch like fun little things that we
put out with source code
um others are a swing for the fences
really think it can become big there's a
company I launched two weeks ago called
Deets like show me the deets
that could be a billion dollar company
you're saying online reviews are broken
you know if you go to Google right now
in quotes you search for buy Amazon
reviews you'll see this 37 000 pages
that tell you how to do that if you make
you know these headphones I'm wearing if
you make a competitive these and you
want to sell it on Amazon you can easily
buy a thousand five star reviews for
that if you want and these fake review
companies are run by PhD computer
scientists they are evading Amazon's bot
detection so it's very difficult at this
point to have to detect them they're
going through proxy servers they have
age accounts they buy products and then
if you go to Yelp or TripAdvisor their
reviews are largely by people you don't
care about
you know like I um looked up a sushi
restaurant in New York and I saw five
star reviews this place people talked
about how great it was because it's
really cheap
and I don't know about you if you like
sushi not but I'm not trying to be that
excited having ten dollars a person but
sushi in New York that's a little scary
to me oh yeah you want that catfish and
cream cheese roll yeah
TripAdvisor and you look for a hotel
you'll see a lot of five-star hotel five
star reviews for Motel Six and that was
great when I was 20 years old I'm not
sure I would stay at Motel 6 now but um
a lot of you just don't relate to the
person doing the purchase so the idea of
Deets are going to blow that up and say
it's just the recommendations from your
friends from influences that you choose
to follow and then using machine
learning doing look-alike modeling to
find people that are similar to you
man it seems like you pick really hard
Industries like uh travel is like uh you
know I'm again I'm an outsider you're
the expert but it seems like notoriously
difficult like it just seems like
incredibly competitive and very very
very challenging and the margins seems
small and very hard it seems to start
one of those things now uh podcasting
terribly hard I don't you know I don't
entirely understand why it's so hard but
like the nothing has entirely clicked to
make it this this fantastic industry uh
even though a lot of people use podcasts
and then reviews also seem terribly
challenging you know Yelp has had like
Yelp hasn't innovated in in five or ten
years their stock sucks uh Google
reviews is is a is a horribly
challenging person to compete with
because you know they have all these
people already using it what what's the
game what's the game plan here and why
are you picking the hardest things to
work on
um
yeah the origin of Dietz is I I'm
friends with some people who own
restaurants in Boston and I saw the
difficult they had during covid and so
it really developed some compassion for
restaurant owners and they all told me
how much they hate y'all Yelp is this
like Mafia where you pay if you they
probably gonna save a lot of bad reviews
call us and pay us hundreds of dollars a
month it will sort of clean up your site
on Yelp it's kind of like in Italy
there's a movie called billion dollar
bully about Yelp it came out in 2019 and
the opening scene is an Italian chef who
said when he opened his first restaurant
in Italy his son broke the windows he
fixed them they broke them in the next
week you fixed them the next week some
guy comes in and says I notice someone
keeps breaking the windows if you pay me
a hundred dollars a week I'll make sure
no one breaks their Windows anymore and
he knew that was the guy who's breaking
his windows he's like Yelp it's just
like that so I look at Yelp as a 20 year
old dinosaur that's the last 20 years we
want to be the next 20 years and I look
at the evolution you know the world is
different now than it was when the
Outback creates did for one the rise of
the influencers particularly gen Z they
make all their purchase decision based
on influencers and that's true not for
dining so we want to give it make it
really easy rather than scrolling
through Instagram and trying to find an
old post of a restaurant you saw a month
ago having it in one tight really clean
UI it's your friends it's your
influencers and then on machine learning
I'm really inspired by tick tock tick
tock's an amazing app they don't ask you
any questions they don't say you know
what do you what's your interest but if
you look at my Tick Tock feed there's a
lot of bass players I'm a bad bass
player but I like bass players there's a
lot of dogs I have a new dog this
gardening Tick Tock has figured out the
stuff I'm interested in and without ever
asking me question and the way they work
is they don't even ask you who your
friends are they will find some you know
DJ in Berlin who has the same weird
sense of humor as you and it'll show you
these are the videos she listens to or
that she watches so I really like that
look-alike modeling I use a cluster ring
so we're doing that with Deeds as well
we're going to find your friends the
influences you like and that people of
the same taste as you
it's wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated whoa I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
do you think that starting a company now
that you're wealthy is easier or harder
than when you are just getting going in
your career I think a lot of people say
it's harder because you don't have the
edge you don't work as hard that's not
true with me if you talk to anyone who
works with me they'll say I'm working as
hard now as I was during my first
company when I was blowing through my
401k to finance it
um
to me work hard is recruit hard
lead coach people get people excited and
I'm working on that as hard as I ever
have I'm trying to get a little bit
better with each company there is some
Advantage having money that if you see
a stupid problem that costs five grand
to fix
you know when you're creating your first
company you don't have that five grand
now you do so you just pay a little
money and problems go away
what do you think Sean easier or harder
uh yeah I think it's different and you
just have to like work with the the pros
and the cons right like yeah recruiting
is easier and you waste less time on the
on just like the rookie mistakes that
you always make but then
you know there is some diminishment
maybe of the edge or
um you know the things that made you
successful the first time might have
been that there was a technology wave
going on there was a bunch of
opportunity and like you have to
recognize new technology waves or new
inflection points new things that have
changed like you know he's talking about
like basically machine learning has
gotten a lot better and now we can do
things that like
make it make the user experience way
different if before we had to ask you 50
questions to show you something good and
now you could swipe three times four
times and I could start getting you
something good
um you know I can create a delightful
user experience whereas before you know
maybe I couldn't so I think
yeah I think it's different and the
things he's saying make a lot of sense
to me I want to tell you one thing about
doing Tech Now versus 20 years ago I've
been investing for a long time in
addition to running companies and in the
old days companies would fail because
their product didn't work they just
couldn't get the check working that's
hardly the case now like the stack the
AWS the tools the open source
um
it's pretty easy to assemble
the right libraries and right people to
help put something together companies
feel today if you wanted two reasons
either there's a Founder implosion they
create a toxic culture and people like
hate their boss and they hate working
there and they all leave which
unfortunately happens all too often they
they fail the culture code
or number two they built a nice product
but it's a real problem that no one
cares about
and unfortunately a lot of Founders have
an itch to scratch as you were saying
earlier Sam
and they get really obsessed about it
like I have this little problem I'm
going to work on it for 10 years and
they don't realize that not a lot of
people have that same problem
it makes me sad when I see that when I
see a beautiful product that solves a
problem I don't care about
yeah you see that all the time that's
like the number one cause of death I
think with uh with startups you uh you
said something a second ago I wanted to
ask you about so you go uh become
amazing at recruiting I um that's never
been something that I was like that's
the thing I'm gonna set my mind to and
you said you know I read all the books I
read listed all the podcasts and try to
become amazing at this so I can assemble
teams to you know do your adventure
Studio
it and um you're pretty good at it
though Sean well I'm just like I don't
know you never know right like even uh
whatever you know like it's like a belt
system it's like even if I'm a blue belt
there's still a black belt you know that
I could go learn from even if you're a
black belt there's they're like oh I'm
I'm just there's lifetimes more to learn
about this thing but I'm curious Paul
how would you summarize
for somebody who's talented but hasn't
put their focus on becoming great at
recruiting what do you think are the um
give me like the the 80 20 the the
summary of what principles you think are
most important when it comes to
recruiting and what are there any that
you wouldn't expect are they all just
things that's like
I want to lose weight so I eat healthy
and exercise like okay well you know I
guess that's true but it's not that not
that helpful I kind of already do that
are there any things that are maybe
counterintuitive or uh or Nuance that
that are important
the main thing is just recruit all the
time always always be recruiting and
always be trying to connect with people
and you might be going to a you know a
coffee social to learn about why
crypto's terrible or whatever
um and you don't realize is someone
going to be there that would be your
next unbelievable CMO you aren't
expecting to meet them but if you always
have your spidey sense out for looking
for amazing people and then once you see
them do whatever it takes to get them to
come meet your team
um I have a little bit of an off-color
story which I probably shouldn't tell
but
um someone asked me once about that's
the strategy by the way that's the best
starting of a story
okay so someone asked me about my
recruiting style because if you've been
recruited by me you'll know that I'm
like very very aggressive to do whatever
it takes to get you I'll come meet you
at a Starbucks near you I'll do it just
get and meet my team I've trained my
team how they should
um behave in their first meeting with
you and all that and the first thing we
can mind when someone asked me about
this about why I'm so laser focused on
getting these people is one time I was
in seventh grade at Boston Latin School
and I was at my locker and this really
cute girl walked by and my friend
noticed me turned my head and look at
her my friend said English don't even
think about it she's dating the captain
the football team so at that moment that
girl went in color and the rest of my
world was black and white like I had to
date that girl just because my friend
said I couldn't and I did end up dating
her but it was just like when I recruit
and I see someone amazing
I've always asked him like do you know
anyone even more amazing than you that's
a funny Japanese game show that is a guy
in Italy looking for the most beautiful
woman in the world and when he
encounters the first beautiful woman in
Italy he says to her do you know any
more beautiful than you and that leaves
us kind of a hilarious uh succession of
conversations but when I'm recruiting
and I find something amazing I'll just
do what it takes to get them excited and
to get them to meet my team and I've
always said that the first five people
hire you the next 50 will hire the next
500 and it's one thing as a Founder to
convince someone to come meet your
company but if you've been really good
at recruiting that first five those five
will close the candidate for you when
they meet those five they'll say oh my
God I need to work with this team you
kind of have I'm clicking around in your
site you and darmesh are interesting to
me because you guys have this like dry
kind of almost nerdy sense of humor that
I love so for example if you go to
lola.com it basically says the domain's
for sale but you can see the history of
Lola by clicking here and it goes to PMD
pme that's you.org and it's a website
where it's like plain text you're just
explaining exactly what happens and so
that's kind of an interesting way of
like going about uh explaining the the
story but if you click paulenglish.com
it goes to your website and it talks
about some of your cool Investments and
your your founder stories and things
like that and then it says like all the
clubs you're involved in and one of them
it looks like either you started or you
are part of the bipolar Social Club I
was reading on your Wikipedia it talked
about like you know you had some issues
with bipolar and I think that like the
fact that you're part of bipolar Social
Club is that's I mean that's just like
that's pretty funny you know uh I I like
I like guys like you and darmesh that's
why I love darmashes he's this guy who's
like
you talk to him and you're like oh
you're just a shy you're pretty shy and
then you start talking a little more
it's like oh you might be like quiet but
you're like you're kind of a killer and
you're incredibly quirky for example
he's got a new project called Venn
diagram.com where it's a community for
people who love Venn diagrams
and uh
and then he has another thing called
like word play or something like that
where it's like a Wordle you know game
that makes like a hundred grand a month
or something crazy like that and he just
has all these things you kind of seem
like that are you a guy who's just
constantly tinkering on on on stuff yeah
I mean I have um I own about 300 domain
names and every domain name has a Google
Document associated with the idea for
the company
um I'm obsessed with brand and names and
I'm in darmesh and I share this that
we're prepared prepared to spend big
money to buy a good name and
um
I do I do it I have lectured a lot of
universities and I gave a lecture on
where creativity comes from and I've
done this everything we're from Berkeley
School of Music Dartmouth film school
Rhode Island School of Design as well as
the more traditional universities you
think about and what I do is let's say
I'm teaching Thursday at five o'clock it
Wednesday at five o'clock I'll have the
professor email with students and say
take a picture of something tonight that
annoys you not a picture you took
yesterday not a picture you found on
Google but take a picture sometime which
annoys you and then I teach the students
about how irritation becomes inspiration
and how any problem can become the
motivation for a product and we go
through a very specific exercise about
how to do that and I am someone who
loves ideating if you look at they say
that you're the average of The Five
People You spend most of your time with
if you want to change your life change
the people you spend time with if you
look at the people who I hang out with
they care about non-profit work
philosophy and ideating like improving
things things I just have a blast
meeting with people like dumbass and
saying how can we fix this how can we do
this better
well you're in the right spot so we stop
when we started this podcast it was it
was doing all right maybe I don't know
10 000 people would listen to every
episode so maybe like I don't know 100
000 in a month something like that and
um it was a classic interview show some
of what we kind of have done so far up
until now getting to know you a little
bit where it's like oh
oh you built kayak amazing tell me about
it you know how'd you do it and it was
just like every other Tech or business
podcast which is how would you do it
podcast and then one day uh just to mix
it up I was like I invited Sam on I was
like Sam let's just shoot the like
we do when we're not on a podcast about
like oh have you seen this yo why
doesn't somebody solve this dude I tried
to book this the other day it was so
annoying and we just started
brainstorming and so we turned the
podcast we called that one the million
dollar brainstorm which is basically
ideas that we don't have the time to do
but
um there were ideas that we thought
could be like you know million dollar
billion dollar ideas and um and so we
started that's what we and then the
whole podcast took off and so now it's
like in the top ranks of the charts and
all this stuff and it's I think because
we switched into this like eye dating
brainstorm mode and there's a lot of
people like us that are out there the
same way darmesh is trying to find all
the Venn diagrammers out there all the
vendors we're trying to find all the
people that love to shoot the and
brainstorm ideas sounds like you're one
of them so can you give us a couple of
of ideas or maybe from your domains you
know pull three names and and what's the
what's the one line pitch you have in
mind for uh for some ideas that you'll
probably never have time to go do
sure
um I'll tell you some ones that the itch
was enough that I actually did a little
bit of work on it
so one of them was I live in Boston but
I also spend a lot of time in New York
where I am today
and where I live is kind of between West
Village and Tribeca
I don't know New York that well like I
know the those three neighborhoods but I
don't really know like Upper East Side
Upper West Side whatever if I'm trying
to meet someone on the upper west side I
don't know what I mean I'm like this is
annoying that there isn't a website
where they can see that where they are
where I am and pick a bar in the middle
so I built an app it's called middle.net
I haven't I bought that domain name and
middle.net allows you to have two people
or three or four as many as you want it
grabs your location from the browser and
it shows you like a coffee shop or bar
to meet in the middle now I'm never
going to make any money doing that but I
did it just because I needed to know
where to meet people in New York because
I was getting used to the city I
couldn't find a way to do it so I built
the nav
um another one when you meet someone so
I generally don't really like going to
conferences because I'm a little bit shy
a little introverted I've like learned
how to be extroverted and I can say more
about that if you care to hear about it
but when you do go to a conference and
you meet someone and you want to swap
info it's annoying to do it you know you
got to type in phone numbers and stuff
better type in email addresses so dumb
or you can use this Dot card thing but
if to carry this card around this card
around so
I designed a little app called Fun
contact it's funcontact.com and allows
you to have a set a list of QR codes one
QR code might be just my email not only
might be my email my home address and
based on who I'm meeting what
information I want to share them I just
swipe through and show them the right QR
code they scan it and I'm in their
address block
um I built that because I needed it I
don't think it'll ever become a company
but I just wanted that so I built it how
many people are using this this looks
cool I'll use it I just needed one of
those things the other day it's super
cool
um I use it last night oh do you wanna
hear a funny story yeah
so
last night was my three-year anniversary
with my girlfriend Rachel
and we went to San Ambrose in West
Village for on our first date three
years ago and next to us was Ann Wintour
you know who she is theater of Vogue
magazine one of the top socialites in
New York and Bradley Cooper on our first
date to set next to us last night was
our three anniversary we go to the same
restaurant guess who's sitting next to
us on a winter that was super cool but
at the end of the meeting I did talk to
her for a couple minutes and then she
left and then the table on the other
side of me was four people working the
fashion industry where my girlfriend
works and we really kind of bonded to
talk about it I talked about the bipolar
Social Club the clothing brand I want to
create
and then they asked my number and I just
pulled out front contact and I scanned
it now all these young fashion people
have my number and we've been messaging
each other today about bipolar Social
Club
that's great what's the clothing brand
you want to create
so bipolar I have bipolar illness I was
diagnosed at age 25 and it's a pretty
serious illness you know a lot of people
end up killing themselves or ruining
their marriage or their job or their
lives
and it took me a good 10 to 15 years to
learn how to manage it for myself it's
bipolar one and bipolar two I'm bipolar
two so I'm not the most severe type the
most severe type his voices they end up
homeless and and or worse
um not that there's a lot of things for
us sending homeless but
bipolar one is pretty serious illness
bipolar 2 still has problems but over
the years I learned how to deal with it
and I want to be able to laugh with
other people bipolar about the funny
things about being bipolar so I created
this video series if you go to
bipolosocialclub.org there's 10 people
with bipolar illness who kind of tell
their Journey
and it's kind of destigmatizing it
saying yeah it's a mental illness and
there's some shitty things about it but
there's some funny things about it too
and I have this thing about bipolar
people that if I'm in a cocktail party
with 100 people and there's someone like
on the other side of the room
I can tell they're bipolar like we
recognize each other
my gay friends say they have gaydar they
can tell gay people across the room I
can tell bipolar people across the room
and we're trying to do something fun so
you want to have a clothing brand where
bipolar people kind of wear the brand
they're proud of like bipolar and proud
so bipolar social club we want just sort
of a fun name
is there anything in uh in the travel
industry that you noticed uh I mean
because you had more data than you know
there's probably only hundreds of people
in the world or maybe low digits
thousands that are able to kind of see
some of the things that you saw because
of the scale of kayak and and the
company that bought you guys were there
any interesting problems that you felt
weren't being entirely solved that you
think could actually be quite large you
know big businesses the problem with the
travel industry is
the thing I had the most trouble with
his flights
and airports and TSA TSA is a joke the
stuff they do to you it gives you a
false sense of security but there's no
real security with GSA
um that's irritating I wish someone
would solve that and make something a
lot more efficient and uh safer airlines
are running on Old technology they have
to be very conservative because if they
make a mistake and adopt something too
new the plane will crash and of course
they don't want that to happen so it's
very archaic and old and
um I said earlier that I travel between
Boston and New York I never fly Because
by the time you go through TSA secured
and get an Uber in each end it's just
it's often faster to drive
so as far as things in the in the travel
industry I would like to see fix I'd
like to see someone that figured out how
to work with all the unions who put all
these requirements in we're working on
the airlines how to work with TSA how to
make flying pleasurable it's not
pleasurable now I also remember growing
up when you go to the airport people
used to dress up
they were like really excited to get on
a plane to travel
by now the airports are just a nightmare
and I wish someone could make airports
Pleasant and make flying Pleasant yeah
same it sounds like the hardest thing on
earth to do though what do you think
about what elon's doing uh so Elon buys
Twitter he's kind of taking this like uh
you know technology first things trying
to change the culture overnight force
people back in the office lay off a
bunch of people try to ship changes
really fast seems a little bit Helter
Skelter have you followed that and I'm
curious what's your opinion as a CTO and
somebody's done tech for a long time I
followed it quite closely and put me in
the list of a thousand people who want
to create a Twitter competitor right now
I've been spending a bunch of time in
the last week ruminating on that
and I think it's a bit of a show I
think I always knew that Elon Musk was
eccentric
and I forgave him for some of his stupid
stuff just because he created such good
products I love my Tesla cars I'm a
happy Tesla stockholder from 2016.
um but when I looked at the way he fired
people at Twitter it was just obnoxious
as like do you really need you're
the richest guy in the room in the world
you really need to also be an
there was no reason you had to March
people out of the office and so when I
saw that I kind of turned on a little
bit
and I said I don't like this guy having
this much power whether he's trying to
control he's trying to make it the main
information source of the world
controlled by the richest person in the
world I'm not very happy about that so
I'm either gonna do you think he's gonna
pull it off he does stupid things like
the Eight dollar verification that was a
joke
um but if he assemble smart people
around him it looks like the smartest
people I'll have left were already
they've all Run for the Hills
but he's going to hire some new people
in I'm sure there's some good people
that are still there
I'm sure he'll do some interesting
things with it but I'm really looking
forward to
all the Twitter Replacements are going
to come out it's hard to compete with an
entrenched company that has hundreds of
millions of users because even if the
product is better does Stephen King
really want to tweet on sampower.com
where there'll be you know a thousand
followers as opposed to Twitter will
have but a million followers but
I don't know I think you stirred stuff
up and I want to see The Innovation that
comes out that's cool
um yeah I think that there's a
I think if somebody's gonna do it
they're gonna have to come up with a uh
a social Innovation not a
it's not a techno it's not a technical
Innovation
um so I have this kind of long-running
theory about social networks which is
that every social network is a change in
privacy policy not a change in
technology so like for example you know
uh Facebook was this privacy policy
change where it was like instead of
Myspace
um this is only people that go to your
school and at the door we gate you with
your your school email address there's a
change in privacy policy that totally
changed people's behavior because now
you're more interested in everybody and
you're more willing to share then as
Facebook became the norm then it became
uh you know things like Twitter which
was like change your privacy policy I
don't have to accept your friend request
for you to see my content it's like you
can just follow me unilaterally you
could just describe you could decide to
get my content that was totally
different than Facebook then Snapchat
comes out it's like here's the privacy
policy here all the self-destructs
at 24 hours or right like in 10 seconds
whatever so content is not permanent
here and so people reflect to that and
so there's just this ongoing shift of
like the what is the like the social
rule set that we're gonna follow on this
thing and so what's interesting with
Twitter is
if you're going to compete with Twitter
now I think you got to do one of two
things you got to do it like kind of
like gab or truth socials trying to do
but somebody could actually pull that
off where they basically take a
community of people that are pissed off
about Twitter and there's enough pissed
off people to go into their own Echo
chamber I think that's possible
um and then the other one is I think if
you created uh you have to turn the
disadvantage into an advantage so
instead of Stephen King saying why do I
want to go tweet here when there's only
I'm only gonna have a thousand followers
over here you have to make it where it's
now benefit like the perk is that
there's only a thousand people there so
it's like more like private or
invite-only style communities that you
can join that have the same content
format as Twitter or something something
like that I think is more likely to work
than what people are trying today which
is just we're Twitter not owned by Elon
Musk or we're a decentralized Twitter
it's like nobody cares uh yeah
centralized is a joke
um I think that's technology looking for
a solution I think truth social was an
epic failure foreign
the things that I care about on Twitter
right now is
I'm bothered by all the trolls and the
cruelty
and um
you know I look at Tick Tock and I don't
watch TV really but I use tick tock
probably 20 minutes a day
and I like how positive Tick Tock is and
I don't know what the Chinese are doing
to filter out the Trolls but it's also
just it's young people like the average
18 year old is like Kinder than the 18
year old now you know do you think
that's true I 100 think it's true I 100
I think that like they don't make fun of
each other in the same way that you and
I used to make fun of our peers at 18.
Twitter I mean Tick Tock is amazing
someone will post a video themself
and they'll say oh my girlfriend just
broke up with me and you know I think
I'm very unattractive or
something like really revealing awkward
and the comments are just unbelievably
supportive yeah it's just amazing it's
so different than Twitter and so I think
it's a Twitter competitor is create the
kind Twitter with his no trolls there's
no cruelty and then also deal with the
misinformation when you see a tweet that
says covet vaccine causes autism like
how do you smack that down and I'm very
interested those two problems getting
rid of Cruelty
and flag misinformation but doing it
without filtering out
independent info like there's a lot of
places in the world right now where it's
scary to be publicly identified and to
State your opinion
and maybe even the us if you're
um there's certain personal problems
like some people might not want to say
they're bipolar because maybe that will
hurt their career
um
but I think there's I think this there
is a way to build something like Twitter
that is kind and Truth oriented and I
haven't spent a lot of time in the last
two weeks bringing some of some other
people are also thinking about doing
something new and I'm confident that
there will be something new whether it's
something that I help people with or
something completely independent I don't
know but somebody needs to create
something better Paul we um I'm gonna
ask you one last question before we have
to move on to the next segment but uh
what's your domain portfolio worth right
now you think
laughs
so I have 300 let's say it cost me ten
dollars
each a year so I'm spending three
thousand a year in domain fees I paid
hundreds of thousands of dollars to buy
domains
I don't sell them that often because I
still hold on to the idea that caused me
to buy the domain so most effort on
occasionally someone will uh motivate me
like a young entrepreneur who has an
idea for demand that I'm not doing
anything with and I'll sell them to them
I don't know I have some that are worth
hundred thousand dollars or more and I
have some that are just funny probably
just to me
Lola would be mid six figures I would
imagine right we paid 500 000 to buy
Lola though we were in a bidding war
it's up for sale again it's on for sale
yeah because we sold the company to
Capital One they want everything to be
Capital One they didn't want the name
Lola so the name is for sale
perfect buy back
possibly
uh okay
um amazing and uh where should people go
find you I'm on your website I think
your website's pretty cool you have like
here's how I manage my time here's how I
run meetings and I love when people do
that when they put their like operating
playbooks out there
um is that the best place to follow you
or should Twitter yeah we're talking
about meditation I talk about getting
rid of pain and suffering I talk about
getting rid of Anger from your life it's
just my name paulenglish.com awesome
well Paul thanks for coming on
appreciate it yeah we appreciate you
doing this
um and uh I'm I'm on your bipolar Social
Club I don't think I have uh bipolar but
I I still think it's fun to follow along
the site so awesome thank you and we
appreciate you coming thanks a lot guys
[Music]